he continues to search for
win number one now kobe originally made
the team as a reliever this year
with the rangers but was inserted into
that rotation after corey kluber
got hurt after just one inning pitched
stella steps in from the left side it's
lefty against lefty
the wine by allard and the one two
offering and that is hit off the foot of
allard and it bounces past
apostle out into left field tommy la
stella
will be credited with a single on a low
line drive that ricocheted off allard's
shoe
and out into left and quickly jacob
nuber and the ranger trainer hustles out
to the mound
to make sure that colby's okay chris
woodward uh right behind him
and you know who do everything first
words out of his mouth i'm fine
and they're going to let colby allard
throw some warm-up tosses to make sure
he's okay
chris bassett making his ninth start of
the season came out of the gate
white hot e.r.a just north of one but
over the last
five or six starts or so has hit a
little bit of a rough patch
and here is solac he went one for three
in the opener getting 269
two homers 20 rbis and the o2 pitched by
bassett is a breaking ball chase that
good curveball down to the dirt so solac
is struck out two away the 2k is
sandwiched around the walk to connor
falefa that'll bring out joey gallo
there's the 1-2 pitch runner going
taking outside throw to second right
there a perfect throw by murphy
and the tag by simeon and connor
philippa no chance
he's cut down trying to steal 2-6 for
the last out of the bottom of the first
and after one the a's and the rangers no
score so now the athletics have two on
and nobody out and lauriana coming up
and he's batting at 217.
here's the one one two ramon it's hit
down the right field side gala going
over has to play it on the hop it's a
fair ball
now gallows and foul territory here's
olson around third
and the throw to the plate and he's
gonna be safe at the plate
olsen is scored chris davis moves up
to second base loriana with the base hit
down the right field line and
davis actually winds up at second it's
one nothing is
rangers thinking about a possible
challenge and the asf runner is at
second and third
and in my mind there's just no question
the call stands olson just got that
right foot in there
so here's murphy where the count of 001
and the ace have the early lead
colby allard throws the 0-1 to murrah if
it's a ground ball
shot into left center for a base hit
that'll score davis lauriano's around
third he will come to the plate
and he will score without a throw and
the ace take a three-nothing lead
do it murph runners on second and third
nobody out little change piece from
colby allen that ball was hit
left of the attempt by the shortstop
isaiah connor philippa
he hasn't got anybody out here in the
second here's the pitch and marcus it's
a shot base at the left
that'll score murphy and they're gonna
hold machine at third and they easily
ate four nothing as simeon ropes a base
set to left
four nothing is in the second and still
nobody out in frustration
because that's gonna do it couldn't get
it out in the second inning
and now la stella steps in lefty against
left here's the o2 pitch and it's swung
on a ground ball to the right side and
through into right for a hit that'll
score a machine
simeon stops at second second baseman
solak
diving to his left couldn't corral it la
stella with another hit
he is two for two today and it's five
nothing in favor of the a's
five runs into the inning bases are
loaded payoff pitch to olson
[Applause]
that's ball four so another run across
six nothing well chris davis is the 11th
hitter in the inning
he walks with the bases loaded here
that's back to back bases loaded walks
given up by hearn and you you saw julio
rondell going to the the phone
this is now a 54 pitch
inning so that'll bring up kinder
philippa and the one strike pitch to the
right hand batter
is a cutter roll towards short simeon to
la stella
to olson 6-4-3 and that is that for
texas
in the third threat do not score on the
fourth inning all oakland leading
seven nothing and here's joey gallo who
struck out swinging
in the second and that ball is hit high
and deep down the right field line
piscotty to his left and this one
falls on the track in fair
territory and uh gets wedged
change up here from chris bassett not a
bad one joey goes out and gets it
catches it off the end of the bat a
little bit
we're catching it off the cap probably
did gallow some favors there
see the top spin on one hour looking to
add on
and that'll bring up simeon here's the
3-2 pitch to marcus and here it is and
marcus it's a deep drive into left
white going back wide at the track right
to the wall
leaping at the wall and it's gone and
simeon has it a three run home run
and these reach double figures it's ten
nothing in favor of the a's
in the fifth inning fastballs swing on
and miss so white case bassett has his
eighth strikeout he's got four in a row
the first pitch
on the bottom of the six and he's hit
the deep left field akana goes back and
reaching over the wall
and makes the catch a wonderful play by
canna
on a bid for extra bases or maybe even a
home run
off the bat of nick soloq and here's
gallow he has struck you out in double
pitch to joey swung on that's hit deep
to right and that's not coming back
that ball is history for joey gallo his
ninth of the year
it breaks the shutout it's now open 10
and the rangers won
sam huff the battery has struck out both
times this ball lined up the middle and
that's a base hit
first hit in sam huff's career somebody
get that souvenir for him
still at second kinder fluffy is at
first and that is a swing and a miss on
that changeup that we were talking about
and that is how the ball game ends and
that's how
the doubleheader comes to an end so the
a's get a
split